The Joe Rogan experience.
Yeah.
The unintended consequences are something
that I've been taken very seriously
lately when I'm paying
attention to technology as a,
as it's used in social media.
Um, particularly the one,
one of the things is disturbed me quite
a bit over the last few weeks is that
there's a model that they use in,
not intentionally,
but there's a model that they use
to get people upset about things,
show you things in your feed that,
uh,
you argue against because that makes
you click on them more and you engage in
them more.
And because of the fact that we have
this advertiser based model where people
are trying to get clicks because they
want to get ads on their page and the more
clicks they get,
the more money they get from those ads.
And so they want to
incentivize people to go there.
And the best way through the algorithm,
what they've found without doing it
on purpose is to get people upset and
they're pushing people into these little
information ghettos that are really
dangerous.
Right.
And we've gotten to this point where this
is just an accepted part of our lives
that you go to check your Google
feed or your Facebook feed and all,
but what the fuck are they doing? Is this
real? They're going to pass this. Yeah.
Goddammit.
And then you get mad and then you engage
with people online and then it results
in more revenue.
But getting them to stop that.
If you had to go to Facebook and say,
hey,
hey mark Zuckerberg and know you have
fucking $100 billion or whatever you got,
but you can't make any
more money this way. Right.
Because what you're doing
is fucking up society. Yeah.
Cause you're encouraging dissent.
You're encouraging people to be upset and
arguments and you're doing it at great
financial reward, but great
societal costs. Yeah. So stop. Yeah.
And he's not going to do it.
Right. Well, he may not do it.
That comes back to the point about
regulation did the question is how big is
your stick? One of the guys who
was the founder of faces yes.
Is now coming out and saying, hey,
Facebook needs to be broken up.
And then he was one of the
original founders and he's like,
it has gotten so far out of hand,
it's so far away from where it is.
It's literally affecting global
politics. Yeah, well it is.
And so one option is to break it up
that it seems to have worked pretty well
with at t and T. Um, another
option is to regulate it,
which I is in my mind would be a
better approach. And that is to say,
here's what's okay and
here's what's not okay.
And this stuff is really intricate.
You have to really get down
beneath these algorithms,
which are unbelievably complex.
But you're exactly right. I mean,
what we're seeing now is we
are being pushed into it.
I said information ghettos,
but it's like information
barricades and so pushed into camps.
Which camp are you on? It's so
dangerous because the old, I mean this,
this country is based on not everybody
agreeing that having a process where
people come and they work it
out and they say, you know,
I'm not perfectly happy with this outcome,
but here's a compromise and if
we can't compromise and our,
our civic culture is going to break
down and there's so much, I mean,
people don't see these pillars
that are holding up our society.
I'd lived in Cambodia for two years and
if you don't have civic pillars under
your society, society's look very, very
different. Everyone's life experiences,
right? We kind of take for
granted. You can go out the door,
walk to Starbucks and not get shot or a,
you can have your house. Something
happened, your house gets Rod,
you call the police and the police aren't
the ones who've robbed your house or
they're not in, I mean there's
all these kinds of crazy things.
If we break down the foundations
that underpin our lives,
that's really dangerous. What I was kinda
getting at was that through what this,
this process of this algorithm,
how this algorithm selects things that,
that chose you in your feet and how
people are getting upset by this and how
this is generating massive amounts of
revenue once it's already happened.
It's very difficult to stop.
And my concern would be that this would
be a similar thing when it comes to
genetic engineering or we're saying we
need to be able to put regulations on
this. We needed to be able to establish
that. But once it gets out of the bag,
once it gets rolling,
and I have,
you remember when Mark Zuckerberg sat
in front of all those politicians,
they had no fucking idea what they
were talking about. You make money.
It's such piss,
poor prepares and it just,
it shows you like these are the
people that are looking out for us.
Good fucking luck. These are Luddites.
They're dumb asses. They're fools, right?
And they're, they don't know anything
about, some are better and worse,
but yet almost everyone was underwhelming
and under impressive in that hearing,
in that hearing.
Yet the fact that they're dealing with
one of the most important moments of our
time,
but they didn't bring on some sort of
a like legitimate technology expert.
It could explain the pitfalls.
Yes. And do so in a way that the,
the rest of the world's could know.
So they're not going to protect us
from genetic engineering either. Right.
Because they are generalists in terms
of their education for the most part and
they're not, they're not
concerned. This is not,
they're concerned with raising
money for their campaign.
The concern with getting reelected.
That's their concerned with, yeah.
I totally agree with you that if we wait
to focus on this issue until it becomes
a crisis,
it's going to be too late because all
the big decisions will have been made.
The reason why I wrote this
book, the reason why, you know,
I'm on my almost week three of this book
tour doing events like this every day
is what I am saying. Every form that I
can is this is really important to you.
Kind of. We were watching the news
yesterday. They had this royal baby in,
in the UK. Like, I don't give a shit.
It doesn't affect my life and anybody.
But what does it play now is the future
of our entire species and our democracy
and our lives.
And we have to be focusing on those things
because we have a moment now where we
can get to a certain extent influence
how these revolutions play out.
And if we just wait around,
if we're distracted and we're focusing
on all this stuff that's sucking up our
attention, and whether it's Trump or
Brexit or Muller and all these things,
I mean, we're spent, how much of our
time are we spending focused on is fine,
let's pay a little bit of attention.
But there's really big stuff
50 years from now, 100 years,
and no one's going to look back and say,
oh,
that was the age of Trump or that they're
going to say that was the age when
after almost 4 billion years of evolution,
humans took control of their
own evolutionary process.
And it's huge and it's
going to change all of life.
And what I'm trying to do is to say
everybody has to have a seat at the table.
Whether you're a conservative Christian,
whether you're a,
a biohacking transhumanist,
everybody needs to be at the table.
Because we talking about is
the future of our species.
We're talking about the
future of our species,
but are we even capable of understanding
the consequences of these actions to
the stuff that we're
discussing like right now,
or I'm not like I'm talking about
it, right? If someone said, hey,
you've got to go speak in front of people
about the consequences of an in a very
clear one hour presentation,
I'd be like, no, I'm not. Well,
I'm what I'm talking about. One, we can go
together. So you're good. Thank you. Um,
but to the reason why I've written this
book hacking Darwin is I want it say if
you could read just one book and it's
written just for everybody in a very clear
way with a lot of jokes
that I think are funny.
My mother laughed at them as well,
that you get it.
And then once you know just the
basics as a human being, anybody,
it has an equal right to be part of this,
of this conversation as the top scientist
or the leaders of any of any countries,
but would agree with you there.
Yeah,
but I don't think that other people
are going to see it that way.
I think the people that are in
control, they're not going to say, hey,
we need to find, we need to be fair with
everyone, all the citizens of the world.
How do you feel we should proceed?
No, but that's why we have to,
that's why we need this
bottom up ground swell.
But we can't have a bottom
up ground swell if people,
if just general people aren't even aware
of what the issues are. And that's,
that's the challenge. And that's why
forums like yours are just so important.
I mean, you have all of these
people and then you know,
maybe everyone doesn't listen to this
podcast. Say, all right, I get it.
I can go give that hour long speech.
But you can read a couple books and then
you can give an an hour speech because
the issues like, yes, there
are scientific issues,
but this isn't a
conversation about science.
This is about values and
ethics in our future.
And it has to be a conversation
for everybody. Yeah.
It's not just a scientific conversation.
It's a conversation about the future of
the species. The species will be awesome.
Yeah. And that's something we're wholly
unqualified. No, it's you. But here's,
here's a little vote for optimism.
Okay.
We have never been this
literate as a species for,
we've never been this educated.
I don't think it was if we ever been
this nice either. Well, I hope so.
I really did want do,
if you look at it,
all the wars and all the murder that
used to happen, it's actually a,
this is the best time ever to be alive.
Still Sucks for people that are
in bad situation. But it's, yes,
on average it's better. And we've
never been this connected. So we have,
so I am the book,
I call for a species wide dialogue on
the future of human genetic engineering.
You think go, well, that's
nuts. 7 billion people on Earth.
How are they gonna how
are they going to do that?
But we have the opportunity and we
have to try. Because you don't want,
look with the beginning of the
genetically modified crops here,
the scientists were
actually really responsible,
but the regular people weren't consulted
and they felt that these guys just did
it to me. So if you have all the marches
with genetically modified organisms,
you that we are entering the
era of genetically modified
humans and that's going
to scare the shit out of people.
And so we need to start preparing and
we need to make people feel that they're
respected and included, and our government
leaders aren't going to do it for us.
So we have to find ways
of engaging ourselves.
And that's why with me with the book, I
set up a website where people can, um,
can share their views,
debate with other people.
I really want everybody to
be part of this conversation.